l'émission politique sur france 2 qui a
pas mal marché un million quatre mille
ans 4 et un mâle pas tant que ça oui
parce qu'on voit que les spectateurs
elle en a marre un peu des émissions
politiques le brouhaha
ça aurait pu être nettement mieux
rangement ça ça ronronne un peu car on
est d'accord alors au en revanche la
veille à une séquence vraiment qui est
et qui était formidable entre marine le
pen et évoqué oui ça nous a d'ailleurs
inspiré une petite parodie jeu on a
réservé un vieux couple
oui qui s'engueulaient donc on s'est dit
bon sur l'été l'un est il enfin l'une et
l'autre dans une petite série ça
pourrait donner un gars une fille y
regarder c'est assez drôle marine le pen
en avril pas très longtemps expliqué que
l'euro avait été un cauchemar pour les
français cauchemar
je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous madame
le pen ce qui serait un cauchemar pour
les français c'est l'affaiblissement de
l'euro
[Applaudissements]
je sais que vous êtes un peu stressé
mais laissez moi parler soirée sinon
encore difficile mais j'aimerais bien
pouvoir dire une phrase moi vous n'êtes
pas un mal aux dents ce tempérament
second tour de la présidentielle ça
faisait longtemps
1 vous savez quoi monsieur wauquiez
j'espère qu'un jour vous aurez la
possibilité de faire un débat a ajouté
la présidence
quand il s'agit de ses trésors à cette
occasion voir si jamais vous avez un peu
augmenté le tarn et de son ambiance
[Musique]
alors dans le débat d'il voquer là il
fait une erreur monumentale que tous ses
conseillers auraient dû lui dire avant
jamais en politique
faire ce qu'on appelle une punchline si
vous n'avez pas imaginer ce qu'on va
vous mettre en retour et lui fait son
truc a en retour il en prend une
du coup je suis désolé on fait pas de
politique non jamais c'est sûr le débat
là il est ridicule mais c'est pas gagné
un gros tacle très la région qui sortent
gagnants de cette de cette base là c'est
elle mais le vrai problème c'est que les
français ne s'intéressent pas au fond et
c'est bien dommage il faut voter
dimanche et parvenir à ce qu'ils disent
est vrai qu'on aimerait partout moi
j'aime ce massage je veux pas donner de
leçons c'est ça que c'est chiant la
politiquement entend tout le temps est
ce qu'on est ce qu'on vit en ce moment
c'est ce qu'on a mis dans le dans les
urnes et j'en dis je n'aurais pas voté
et après turin mais tout ça c'est à
cause de l'europe à l'égal sa cause de
l'europe il faut aller voter quand même
la raison d' injuste je mets mon grand
père en faisant jouer les à l'aller les
vieux gagner mais à l'époque de l'heure
de vérité ça marchait la politique à la
télévision
alors en fait pourquoi ça marche moins
sur les grandes chaînes nationales comme
ça c'est parce qu'au quotidien
on a maintenant toutes les chaînes info
on a le plus grand nombre de chaînes
d'info en europe on à bfm effectivement
ces news là les meilleurs sessegnon on
avale à france info télé etc et on a
trop de chaînes d'info qui donne l'info
toute la journée
et justement les chaînes comme tf1 avait
créé lci la première chaîne d'info pour
se libérer de la politique alors donc
réelle refonte de la politique ça marche
pour moi j'ai un regret c'est que cyril
n'ai pas fait un bal en son poste
spécial européenne ça va donner un petit
coup d'oeil aux débats